you won't be penalized for the most
beautiful thing you can do have you met
before
the situation is different but I've come
across thousands who are juggling family
life and professional life very very
well I think it's very achievable what I
can promise you since I'm the CEO of
this company you taking time for that
won't hurt your career you won't be
penalized for the most beautiful thing
you can do for our business the longer
people stay here the better we'll be at
what we do for me that goes back to if
you do the right thing the right things
will happen I want people to stay here
for as long as possible and if we create
a great culture then they will